So, if you've been leading youth for any time, you've probably done a retreat.
And if you've been leading youth for any time, you've done a retreat,
then you've probably
had that mountaintop experience where students that you denied all expect would meet
Jesus
in that space.
They did.
It was awesome.
And you loved every minute of it, right?
And then you come down from the mountains, so to speak.
And then Monday comes.
And all of a sudden, it starts to feel like we're right back to where we were.
And I think a lot of that is because it's super cool to love Jesus when we're at
camp.
And everybody around us loves Jesus.
And it's super cool to talk about the typoship and spiritual formation and talking
about
Jesus to the lost and going out and being a witness for Christ in a world that
desperately
needs to heal the gospel.
All that super cool to talk about and is exciting when we're like in this little
pressure cooker
of Christians.
And so often we go out and we send our students out and they come back the same way
they
were and we're like, what the heck happened?
And it's because Christianity is not super cool out there.
It may be super cool in your youth group, which that's awesome,
but it's not necessarily
super cool out there.
It's easy to be a Christian inside a context of a youth group, right?
It's easy to be a Christian when we're up at camp.
It's easy to be a Christian around much Christians.
What happens when we need to be a follower of Jesus around everyone else?
Not so easy.
And one thing that your students are going to get a chance to learn this week is
about
the lives of the apostles.
Now we don't know a whole lot about the lives of the apostles,
but what we do know is that
many of them gave and all of them were willing to give their lives for the message
that they
preached.
And I love what Peter and John say in Acts 4.20 that we can do nothing but speak at
the things that we have seen and heard.
Even in the face of persecution where they're being told,
don't speak about Jesus anymore
because if you do, there are going to be serious consequences.
Guess what?
They are like, no, not going to do it.
I'm still going to talk about Jesus.
You can't stop us and there's nothing that you can do to us to stop us.
That's awesome.
And I've, several times I've prayed like, man, God, can I just have that kind of
boldness?
And yeah, I've done the whole thing with my students have asked them, you know,
if someone held their gun to your head and told you to denounce Jesus, would
you, you know, and that may be becoming more of a reality in our world now more than
ever.
But the bottom line is, is we want our students to see the power of the Holy
Spirit in our lives and the power of the gospel and how it ought to compel
us to move into spaces where the gospel needs us most despite the fear, despite
the difficulty.
And that really becomes the focus this week as you kind of get into some
things.
We want students to know that the apostles were not liars that despite what
some people say, they didn't make this stuff up because why would you give your
life over for something that you know is completely a lie?
That doesn't quite work.
And that they're willing to die for this belief.
That's a profound reality for our students to kind of get after.
And it'll be, it should be a very transformative experience for them.
Okay.
So I know what many students are probably going to say to you and you're
probably going to hear this.
Others have died for their belief, especially in our world, we hear about all
the time, especially with terrorism, that others die for their belief.
What makes the apostles so much different, right?
They're fervent too.
They think what they believe is right.
How come the apostles, yeah, that's, that's absolutely true.
But here's the difference.
And this is something you're going to hear Sean say, I'm just
going to echo it.
If I died for my faith and I proclaimed it to be true, that's
just because I think it's true.
It doesn't necessarily make it true.
It's because it's been passed down to me and what I, I think I've
got it all figured out.
I think I've got it all right.
And I'm going to believe that I do.
But the difference is, is that the apostles saw and were eye witnesses
to Jesus.
They, that's why they're apostles is they actually lived
with Jesus, walked with Jesus, saw him die, saw him resurrect or
given the instructions and they died as a result of that belief.
And it's a direct correlation, right?
So you've got, you've got this piece that is, here is Jesus, this
counter cultural, you know, public figure icon, you know, religious type
person that is spreading news that is totally contrary to what the main
line beliefs, whether you were Jewish or Roman were.
So it would, there was fear, there was animosity, there was like, who
is this guy?
What is he doing?
What's going on?
So once he was gone, it was like, whew, he's out, we're done.
Let's move on.
And then all of a sudden these apostles, these people that were
with Jesus start carrying this on.
Now imagine for a moment that this is not true.
And you're one of the apostles and you get told, shut it down or you're
going to lose your life.
What do you pick?
I'm not going to carry this lie.
There's nothing in it for me.
What do I care?
You're not going to die for something you know is a lie.
But they so believed it, the resurrection changed them so much
that they were willing to end their, you know, have their lives put
to an end in some horrific ways, mind you.
Now it doesn't prove anything beyond the shadow of a doubt, but it
does show that the apostles were not lying.
So in your small group time, focus in on the student discussion
questions.
Specifically, how would you describe the conviction the
apostles had for their message?
Dive into that a little bit deeper.
Like how would you describe their conviction?
And do you agree with their conviction?
Ask your students honestly, did these apostles seem absolutely
out of their minds?
Like why would you do this?
Or is there something more going on here?
And help them make the connection of what if you were there?
Try to connect them to and bridge the gap between then and
now and bring your students into that space now.
Find an example, find something that will help them understand
if you absolutely saw something and you knew it to be true.
How far would you go to make sure that truth came out?
How far would you go?
We see it all the time in movies and media and music and other
places where we want the truth to come out and we're willing
to go to great lengths to make sure of that.
So how far would they go?
And the third one is what fate did the apostles meet due to
their relentless devotion to spreading the gospel?
Have them look back into that.
Now there's some wide disagreement on the exact fate of
some of the exact ones and you can look into that.
Be careful what you find if you go looking on the internet.
Not all of it is 100% accurate.
There's some things that are church tradition,
not necessarily historically accurate,
but it still makes the point that they did suffer
and die as a result.
How they suffered and died is a little bit up for debate,
but we know that they did for sure.
And lastly, what does the apostles' fate mean
for the faith of your students?
This is kind of going to get into the nitty-gritty of things.
Because this seems so distant, right?
This seems so far off, something so old,
and it doesn't really matter anymore.
It doesn't concern me.
I'm in my nice comfy, whatever.
It's fine.
Bring it.
What does it mean for them?
Have them think that through and talk through specifically.
Make them dig deep.
They kind of give an answer that you're like,
why?
Ask them to go a little bit deeper
and really pull out of them what it would mean.
And what does it now mean moving forward?
How are they going to live differently?
How are they going to act differently knowing this information?
Then take some time
and look back at what you've looked at
over the last couple of weeks.
You've got miracles.
A miracle is verifiable.
It's testable.
We know that miracles exist.
We see the greatest miracle in the history of the world
in the resurrection of Jesus.
That resurrection miracle
solidifies the claim that Jesus is God,
the Creator of all.
And that that message of the gospel
and who Jesus is and what was going on in the world
was so compelling, so powerful,
so life-changing that the apostles
who saw it, witnessed it and lived it
died because of it.
That's powerful, powerful testimony.
Have your students look back
on the whole blanket of concepts
that we've just laid out over the last four weeks.
Have them take a hard look at their faith
and say, now how do I move with all this knowledge?
I can't stay here.
I can't just know this and move on.
Now that I know all of this,
what does it look like for me
moving forward in my walk with Christ?